nation security and agriculture
this is a truly historic day
there had been two peace agreements with
israel
in the last 72 years this is now
the second peace agreement that we've
announced in the last month
and i am very hopeful that there will be
more to follow i can tell you this
tremendous enthusiasm on behalf of other
countries
to also join and we think ultimately
you'll have most countries join and
you're going to have the palestinians
in a very good position they want to
come in they're going to want to come in
because all of their friends are in but
we have tremendous enthusiasm for coming
into the deal i want to thank the
group of very talented people behind me
and you're going to be hearing from them
in a second but
it's just a very historic day a very
important day and so interesting that
it's on
9 11. it's uh it's such a great
time we didn't know this was going to
happen in terms of the timing
but it did happen and we're very honored
by when i took office the middle east
was
in a state of absolute chaos
i've restored trust with our regional
partners and together we've
eliminated the isis caliphate 100
isolated the radicals who pervert islam
and so instability today nations across
the region and throughout the world
are joining together united in the
determination to build a better future
free from the evils which perpetuate
terror
and i think you see that i think you see
that happening very very strongly
i also spoke with king solomon of
saudi arabia and we talked about this
and he is
he's a great gentleman and what they've
done in terms of fighting terror is a
much different
ball game than it was before we
attained this office the fact is that
saudi arabia was doing things that
they're not doing anymore
and so are other countries and neighbors
they are doing things that they just uh
would never have done their uh their
levels and their
uh all of the things all of the many
many uh
elements of uh fighting and hate
they seem to be evaporating and we'll
find out very soon but they seem to be
evaporating so things are happening in
the middle east that nobody thought
was even possible to think about and
that's what's going on right now bahrain
has agreed to join
israel and the united arab emirates for
and by the way i want to thank muhammad
who is a great leader a truly great
leader
at the white house on tuesday so they'll
be here on tuesday for the signing of
the
abraham accords the significance of the
signing will be
elevated from an already historic
breakthrough to
one representing a previously
unthinkable regional transformation
and that's exactly what it is it's
unthinkable that this could happen and
so fast
and as you know when we did the
original signing with and which will
actually take place in terms of official
on tuesday united arab
emirates people thought that was
amazing and now they're hearing this and
they're also hearing from other
countries because they understand that
other countries want to very much come
in
on this occasion i want to thank the
leaders of israel and bahrain for their
vision and courage to forge this
historic agreement their leadership is
proving that
the future can be filled with hope and
does not need to be
predetermined by conflicts of the past
uh you know all about the conflicts of
the past they're very legendary there
was
a lot of problems going on but we've
been able to
work things out to a level that nobody
thought possible
this is really something very special
very very special as more countries
normalize
relations with israel which will happen
quite quickly
we believe the region will become more
and more stable secure and prosperous
in the meantime we're pulling most of
our soldiers out so we're doing it the
opposite way they were doing it with
nothing but fighting and blood all over
the place
the sand was loaded up with blood
and now you're going to see that a lot
of that sand is going to be loaded
up with peace the united states will
continue to stand with the people of the
region and work with them and build a
brighter
and much more hopeful future so we're
very proud of this
and as time goes by i think you'll see
more and more why i think most of you
realize how important it is even the new
york times was very
generous in their praise of the original
deal and they never thought
i think nobody thought this was going to
happen so quickly after the first but
they'll both be here on tuesday they're
going to be signing
benjamin netanyahu will be here prime
minister will be here
israel and we look forward to that
just on this deal because of the
importance of the deal we'll take some
questions
but first i'd like to ask jared to say a
few words and
mike pence to say a few words and some
of the folks david i'd like you to say
something about it because it's so
historic and these people have worked so
hard and so long on it
this is really the culmination of
a long period of time let's put it that
way i don't want to say how long but
it's been
it's a long period of time it's a great
thing jared please
thank you mr president and first i want
to thank you for your leadership on this
issue your first
foreign trip was to saudi arabia where
you outlined division for the region
and all of the promises you made on that
trip and all of the things that you
foreshadowed have occurred it's been
a strategy that you've stuck with and i
want to thank you for
giving me the trust and confidence that
you've given me in order to work on this
file over the last years and and i think
the results that we've achieved has been
beyond anyone's
expectations and i believe that there's
even more to come i just
returned from the region last week i was
in the middle east where
i took the first commercial flight
that's ever flown from israel to the
united arab emirates
that flight flew over saudi arabian
airspace it was the first time in 72
years
that saudi arabia has now waived their
airspace
to allow commercial flights to fly from
israel back and forth
bahrain then did the same thing the
united arab emirates waved a 48-year
boycott israel which was an incredible
development
and there are now delegations moving
throughout the middle east figuring out
how to bring the people closer together
what president trump has done here is
unthinkable he's brought
people in the middle east together
there's been these barriers that have
existed that have
led to so much instability uh so much
war so much loss so much hopelessness
and we're seeing so much hopefulness now
coming and i will say something that
i never thought would be the case which
is that on this last trip the amount of
optimism
that has happened that we're
experiencing the middle east is truly
incredible so
i just want to congratulate you i want
to congratulate the people of israel i
want to congratulate
the people from the kingdom of bahrain i
want to thank their tremendous
leadership
and i also uh want to congratulate the
people of the middle east
because the first deal that you were
able to accomplish was so popular
that things are really starting to move
in uh in a really strong direction and
this makes america safer it allows us to
uh to bring our troops home and allows
us to uh work on
bringing prosperity to american
communities so really thank you for your
leadership
congratulations on this great success
great job thank you very much mike
please
mr president i can think of
no more fitting tribute to the heroes
that were forged on this day 19 years
ago
and all the heroes that were forged on
battlefields
ever since than to see this peace
agreement announced today
and mr president i you said from early
on
that we could stand with israel and we
could stand for peace
your very first foreign trip was to the
arab world to reach out
to create new alliances you affirmed our
support
for israel when you moved the american
embassy to jerusalem
and the strength with which you have
approached this
has made now this second historic peace
agreement possible
and i just want to i want to
congratulate you and thank you mr
president for your leadership
i also want to i want to thank the
people of the kingdom of bahrain
and the people of israel for finding a
way forward
to begin to take one more step toward
peace in the middle
east and to know that in this president
and in the american people they will
have an ally with us
the good book says blessed are the
peacemakers and mr president i just want
to congratulate you
i want to congratulate prime minister
netanyahu
and king ahmed of bahrain on bringing
peace
between their nations and widening the
reach of peace in the world
congratulations thank you very much mike
great
uh our wonderful ambassador to israel
david friedman who has been really
something he's been uh
i put him there i knew him for a long
time he was one of the most successful
lawyers in the country
by far and uh at least based on his
paycheck i can tell you that
and uh he's a great lawyer he's a great
talent and a great deal maker
and i put him there for a reason i put
him there to get it done
i said just don't be a regular
ambassador like so many are
just get it done see if you can bring
peace to the middle east
david please thank you mr president and
i will always be indebted to you for
giving me that honor it's one that
i i hold extremely uh dear well
as you know mr president people have
thought about the middle east for the
past hundred years or more as a place of
violence of hopelessness
of suffering of war what we're seeing
real time
in this room today and last month
we're seeing the paradigm of the middle
east completely change
the world is turning in a very positive
way
and um it's all because if i may say
because of the policy that you began in
may of 2017 of trusting our allies
of empowering our allies in my case of
course of
being the greatest friend that israel
has ever had
uh of putting people on the job who
share those values and convictions and
the fruit is now being born in this
incredible peace agreement
your policy of peace through strength
has changed the world profoundly for the
better
and i'm as the ambassador to israel
i am eternally grateful for the changes
that you have made
for the u.s israel relationship thank
you david great job
thank you avi please thank you mr
president
uh congratulations
thank you mr president congratulations
on just a tremendous historic
um you know achievement here today i
think i just speak for everybody in this
room all of my colleagues who have
worked
in your administration that thanks to
your leadership there's just a
tremendous sense of pride to be an
american
to work on on these issues under your
leadership and
i'm just so appreciative to you and so
honored to be part of your team so thank
you
mr president i think historians will
look back on these two peace agreements
as the beginning of the end
of the arab-israeli conflict and
you talked about the journey to get here
and i remember
i heard you pledge when you were in
riyadh and when you were in israel
you pledged that you would strengthen
america's friendships
and to build new partnerships in the
pursuit of peace
and you kept that promise and we see
that very clearly today
rather than appeasing america's
adversaries in the region
you recruited america's allies and
you focused on shared interests and
shared threats
but you also asked them to shoulder
their part of the burden
and to fulfill their end of the
obligation nations rallied behind it
and as a consequence the foundation has
now been laid for
great things in the coming years
great well said thank you very much
would you have anything to
say mr president uh on behalf of
soldiers sailors airmen and marines
thank you for your bold leadership and
sheikh mohammed's bold leadership
prime minister netanyahu's goal
leadership king hamad's
bald leadership sheikh mohammed bin
zayed again
your bowl leadership what we've tried
for the last hundred years has not
worked
uh i think it's very fitting that on
september 11th we honor those special
operators that we've buried and lost
uh with with peace and this is a way to
beat terrorism at the end of the day so
we're honored and privileged and thank
you for your leadership well they had a
lot of bad thinking a lot of bad
concepts a lot of
things that i never thought were gonna
work uh
these were the ones that we were relying
on to make the deals and they
wasted 35 years they wasted many many
years
and they're the ones that have been
critical of us and look what's happening
now they're all of a sudden saying i
think they made a mistake
they're all saying that about themselves
i just want to thank this group
in particular for staying here and
helping us out
and doing things that nobody thought
could have happened and under the old
concepts of
national defense or whatever category
you want to put it under
it that wasn't working and it was never
going to work
and we changed things around very
drastically and then we started to
negotiate and
the good news i look at david because
you know it you see it you hear it
the good news is we have many other
countries now in the middle east that
want to be
in this and that means peace because
they're tired of fighting you know they
can fight and they're all great fighters
and their warriors
but even great warriors get tired of
fighting and they're tired of fighting
and i can see things positively
happening with iran
ultimately i think that can all work out
very well and i think that
so many great things are going to happen
and then we can
also discuss the palestinians i think
the palestinians are going to end up
doing something that's going to be very
smart for them and all their friends are
coming into this and they want to come
into it they want to come into it very
badly and i can see a lot of good things
happening with respect to the
palestinians which would be really
wonderful whether you were on their side
or not on the side
people want to see it all brought to an
end and brought to an end quickly so
that's going to be very important but
this is a very historic day would
anybody else like to say anything please
please mr president i just want to thank
you and
ambassador o'brien uh for giving me the
opportunity to serve on the national
security council staff and be part of
something
uh historic and be part of a team
avi and jared are tremendous leaders and
the opportunity to work with them
to do something important has been the
highlight of my life and thank you for
letting me do that sir and you've been
doing this for a long time you never saw
anything like this
we take a little bit of a different
approach
anybody please come on my friend mr
president uh
19 years ago today my father and i
almost got caught in the crosshairs of
that first jet
that hit the twin towers that event
changed the course of my life it led me
to become a united states marine which
led to other things that uh
brought me uh through a strange path uh
here
uh and uh i wanna thank you for the
leadership you've shown
walter russell mead recently wrote he
was quoting
churchill who once said he got a bowl of
pudding he said take it away it has no
theme
there's now a theme emerging in the
middle east
and uh it is the theme of what is
possible from peace through strength
from not appeasing our enemies and and
holding our allies and friends close
so uh congratulations sir thank you very
much this is a very very big day
very very big day would you like to say
something mr like uh
like matt and many others 19 years ago
within a month of the attacks on 9 11
i and others were conducting operations
in afghanistan
as general correa pointed out it's a
privilege to be in different historic
circumstances today
to be part of a tremendous team within
outstanding leadership
all of it possible sir because of your
vision because of your leadership in the
relationships of everyone in this room
it's an enormous opportunity uh it's
something that no one can imagine
but it's an enormous privilege and
always be grateful for it so
congratulations to you sir
and thank you to you and everyone else
here well it is an honor to have worked
with all of you
you're really talented people incredible
and you are willing to be flexible the
word flexible is a very important word
because
we weren't going by the old standards
and norms we're going by standards that
can get things done but not only get
them done get them done in a much better
way
and this is just the beginning a lot of
things are happening and they're
happening very
quickly people want to be involved and
they want to be involved for the first
time i think
some of you have told me the first time
ever that you've ever seen anything like
this where they're
rushing into an agreement they want to
be involved
they're tired of fighting as i said
they're tired of fighting
no matter how they are no matter how
great a warrior they are and you have
some great warriors i know most of them
but it's time thank you all very much
mr president can we ask you about this
thank you we're leaving
thank you
oh yeah i'm sorry